I like bulldozers too it's a lot easier
than cleaning the snow by hand but it's
not a contribution to science you can
fool reporters that you shouldn't be
able to full computer scientists first
we should ask the question whether large
language models have achieved anything
anything in this domain answer no
they've achieved zero so to talk about
the failures that's beside the point
supposedly submitted an article to a
physics journal saying I've got a
fantastic new Theory and accommodates
all the laws of nature the ones that are
known the ones that have yet to have
been discovered and it's such an elegant
theory that I can say it in two words
anything goes okay when you have a
theory there are two kinds of questions
you have to ask why are things this way
where are things not that way if you
don't get the second question you've
done nothing ppt3 has done nothing